la muerte del baterista de foo fighters
teilón hopkins hace tan solo un día ha
dejado conmocionados a cientos de miles
de fans en bogotá a colombia algunos de
ellos le rindieron homenaje y
prometieron no olvidar su legado
no va a seguir
todos son importantes pero creo que de
taylor eran
el baterista de foo fighters tenía
planeado tocar junto a la banda en un
importante festival colombiano el
estéreo picnic donde miles de fans lo
esperaban hopkins era uno de los
miembros más importantes del grupo
musical al que se unió a finales de los
90 y el que siempre aparecía junto al
vocalista dave grohl en las entrevistas
también sirvió de inspiración para
muchos músicos o sea duro yo toco la
batería entonces él ha sido como una
inspiración muy grande
es el tema de su muerte que fuera tan
repentina quería hacerle un homenaje a
una de mis bandas favoritas un gran
artista de exterior rock kings
un baterista reconocido a nivel mundial
no sólo como músico sino
su parte espiritual él era una persona
muy alegre y se identificaba con la
gente por eso ahora son muchos los que
lloran su pérdida y sobre todo agradecen
su contribución al mundo de la música y
el rock por décadas